[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Spaß
[Musik]
Kritik von unabhängigen Experten mit
ihren Gesetzesplänen weiche die
Bundesregierung den Klimaschutz auf
höchster Verdienstorden für Angela
Merkel an der Ehrung der ehemaligen
Bundeskanzlerin gibt es auch Kritik
und 100 Jahre Disney-Welt eine
Ausstellung in München von Micky Maus
und Schneewittchen über Star Wars bis zu
den Marvel-Helden
es ist ein schlechtes Zeugnis für die
Klimapolitik der Bundesregierung der
Expertenrat für Klimafragen überprüft
regelmäßig die Selbstverpflichtungen zum
Klimaschutz regelmäßig warnen die
Wissenschaftler Deutschland ist zu
langsam heute setzen sie noch eins drauf
sie sehen die große Gefahr dass die
Ampel mit ihren änderungsplänen das
Klimaschutzgesetz verwässert Christian
Volk berichtet
zu hohe CO2-Emissionen in Deutschland
etwa auf den Straßen oder beim Heizen
mit Öl und Gas zwar ging der Ausstoß der
Treibhausgase 2022 gegenüber dem Vorjahr
leicht zurück aber nicht wegen der
Politik sondern wegen äußerer Umstände
sagt der Klima Expertenrat was wir auch
in einer vertieften Analyse festgestellt
haben dass die
Treibhausgasemissionen um rund 9
Megatonnen höher gelegen hätten im
vergangenen Jahr wenn das Wachstum der
Wirtschaftsleistung nicht in Folge des
Krieges der Ukraine in der Ukraine
geringer ausgefallen wäre als erwartet
die ampelregierung will nun das
Klimaschutzgesetz ändern und die
sektorenziele aufweichen bedeutet wenn
etwa das Verkehrsministerium sein Klima
Ziel verfehlt dann könnte ein anderes
Ministerium diese Differenz ausgleichen
ein Fehler sagen die unabhängigen
Wissenschaftler
wir sehen eigentlich dass wir in keinem
Sektor wirklich auf einem guten Weg sind
und das heißt auch wenn wir aggregiert
betrachten ist das nicht so dass ein
Sektor dem anderen was ausleihen könnte
Umweltorganisationen kritisieren die
Beschlüsse der Koalition seit Wochen sie
sehen sich bestätigt es zeigt sich
gerade im Verkehrsbereich das
Deutschland überhaupt nicht auf
klimakurs ist und hier ist eine
dringende Korrektur über Sofortmaßnahmen
notwendig doch nur wenige Stunden nach
der Pressekonferenz des expertenrates
diese Erklärung aus dem Kanzleramt das
Verkehrsministerium seit trotz des
überhöhten CO2-Ausstoßes von der Pflicht
eines Klima Sofortprogramms befreit
jetzt zur höchsten Auszeichnung die
Deutschland zu vergeben hat das
Großkreuz des
bundesverdienstordens in besonderer
Ausführung erst zwei Mal würde es
verliehen
1954 an den ersten Bundeskanzler Konrad
Adenauer
1998 an Helmut Kohl den Kanzler der
Einheit wer den Orden bekommt
entscheidet der Bundespräsident und der
hat vor einer halben Stunde Angela
Merkel ausgezeichnet was auch Kritik
auslöste Bernd Bett
im kleinen Kreis bekommt Angela Merkel
das große Kreuz 20 Gäste durfte sie
einladen Familie Freunde der Enge
politische Zirkel auch zwei ihrer
Vizekanzler sind dabei der eine ist ihr
nachgefolgt der andere verleiht dir
heute den höchsten Verdienstorden den
der Bundespräsident verleihen kann
sie haben mit ihrer kanzlerinnenschaft
dafür gesorgt dass eine Frau an der
Spitze der Regierung das auch weibliche
Macht für immer
eine Selbstverständlichkeit in unserem
Land sein würden Merkels Dankesrede
denkbar kurz ein Dank an die
Wegbegleiter kein Wort zur Politik in
diesem Sinne stehen die jetzt
vorgestellten Personen nicht nur für den
heutigen Abend sondern sie stehen dafür
dass
ganz viele Menschen dazu gehören wenn
man 16 Jahre Bundeskanzler ist bei denen
kann ich mich jetzt nur auf diese Weise
bedanken viele im politischen Berlin
gratulieren heute zu der Auszeichnung
nüchtern kommentiert das ganze der jetzt
Vorsitzende von Merkels eigener Partei
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz war genau wie
Vertreter der CSU nicht eingeladen
das ist die souveräne Entscheidung des
Bundespräsidenten und es ist die
souveräne Entscheidung von Frau Merkel
wer heute Abend dazu eingeladen wird das
werde ich öffentlich nicht bewerten und
nicht kommentieren so war mir Gott Hilfe
16 Jahre war Angela Merkel im Amt seit
gut 16 Monaten ist sie es nicht mehr aus
Teilen der Opposition heißt es ein
Stelle eines Ordens müsste es
Aufarbeitung geben etwa von Merkels
außen Energie sozial oder Klimapolitik
die Energiewende wurde verschleppt die
Kinderarmut ist in der Zeit dramatisch
gestiegen die soziale Ungleichheit hat
zugenommen ja und das finde ich muss man
auch kritisch reflektieren ich denke man
kann den Orten verleihen und trotzdem
vielleicht auf die kritischen Punkte auf
die Fehler der Regentschaft Merkel
schauen Frau Merkel hat sich sehr
verdient gemacht als eine
krisenkanzlerin es ist ein Orden der in
seiner Zeit gesehen werden muss und
nicht zehn Jahre später Bilanz ziehen
Adenauer hat den Orden mitten in seiner
Amtszeit bekommen Kohl am letzten Tag
als Kanzler Merkel ist jetzt die erste
großkreuzträgerin und die erste die der
Orden im Ruhestand erreicht
in Berlin schauen wir noch mal auf die
CDU eigentlich müsste die doch
begeistert sein wenn ihre Kanzlerin und
ehemalige Parteichefin so hoch dekoriert
wird
ja das stimmt aber aus dieser Beziehung
CDU und Angela Merkel ist seit längerem
nicht unerheblicher Teil der
Begeisterung gewichen und zwar
beidseitig wir haben viele ranghohe CDU
Stimmen angefragt aber nicht allzu viele
wollten sich lobend über die
ex-kanzlerin äußern und ja auch
umgekehrt spricht Merkels persönliche
Gästeliste Bände sie hat schlichtweg
niemanden aus der aktuellen Parteispitze
eingeladen ein größerer zeitlicher
Abstand zu merken sie haben seit hätte
dieser Ordens Entscheidung
möglicherweise gut getan den der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
liegt aktuell wie ein Schatten auf
Merkels Kanzlerschaft auf ihrem
verfehlten versucht Putin einzubinden
auf der zu großen eingegangene
Energieabhängigkeit Merkels Verdienste
sind natürlich unbestritten Stabilität
Verlässlichkeit Wohlstand wurden
herausragend aber ein Abwarten der
geschichtlichen Bewertung hätte sicher
nicht geschadet immerhin wurde weder
Willy Brandt noch Helmut Schmidt dieser
höchste ordent verliehen
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung live
aus Berlin theol
entsetzt blickt die Welt auf ein Urteil
in Moskau weil er Putins Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine scharf kritisiert
hatte verurteilte ein Gericht Vladimir
karamusa zu 25 Jahren straflage mit
besonders harten Haftbedingungen das ist
das bisher höchste Strafmaß gegen einen
Oppositionellen der 41-Jährige
Familienvater gehört zu den bekanntesten
Kritikern Putins Nina Niebergall hat
mehr
Vladimir karamusa trifft die ganze Härte
des putin-regimes gegen das er so lange
gekämpft hat zwei giftanschlägen zum
Trotz vor wenigen Tagen seine letzten
Worte vor Gericht
ich sitze wegen meiner politischen
Ansichten im Gefängnis weil ich mich
gegen den Krieg in der Ukraine
ausgesprochen habe weil ich jahrelang
gegen Putins Diktatur gekämpft habe ich
bereue nicht nur nichts von alledem ich
bin stolz darauf
festgenommen wurde er nach einer Rede
vor dem Senat in Arizona
heute sieht die Welt was das
putin-regime der Ukraine antut die
Streubomben auf Wohngebiete auf
Entbindungsstationen Krankenhäuser und
Schulen das sind Kriegsverbrechen die
von dem diktatorischen Regime im Kreml
begangen werden
diese Worte für Putins Regime
Falschinformationen eine Straftat später
kommt der Vorwurf Hochverrat dazu
jahrelang kämpfte karamursar gegen
staatliche Willkür an der Seite von
Alexander valny und Boris nemzoff der
2015 erschossen wird in den Jahren
danach die Giftanschläge auf karamusar
er ließ seine Familie in den USA und
kehrte trotz aller Gefahr bewusst nach
Russland zurück
Entsetzen heute bei einem der letzten
Oppositionellen der in Russland noch auf
freiem Fuß ist
dieses Urteil ist nur noch mit der Zeit
Stalins vergleichbar besonders
ungeheuerlich ist die Tatsache dass es
eine Strafe für Worte ist das zeigt
deutlich dass die Behörden sogar Angst
vor Worten haben
seit den gifternschlägen 25 Jahre in
einem russischen Gefängnis das könnte
sein Todesurteil sein
wir sind geschlossen und entschlossen
daran lassen die Außenminister und
außenministerinnen bei der G7 bei ihren
Gesprächen in Japan keinen Zweifel und
diese Botschaft geht an Russland in
gleichem Maße wie an China doch die Hand
nach Peking bleibt ausgestreckt
Zusammenarbeit auf Augenhöhe so das
Angebot von Tag 2 des Treffens der
wirtschaftsstärksten Demokratien im
japanischen Ferienort carouzawa
berichtet Andreas Künast
die Einwohner des Urlauber Örtchens
caroitsawa finden sich an diesem Morgen
in einer anderen Welt wieder es sind
sieben Gäste in der für ihre Ruhe
berühmten Stadt die jetzt weltberühmt
ist aber nicht mehr ruhig
[Musik]
auch für die G7 ist die Welt eine andere
seit nach Russland auch China mit Krieg
droht für den japanischen G7 Vorsitz ein
Wendepunkt der Geschichte
wir werden jegliche Versuche
zurückweisen den Status Quo mit Gewalt
zu ändern
China und Russland sind die großen
Anwesenden abwesenden am Tisch der G7
Thema gestern Taiwan Thema heute Ukraine
weiß wann der Tag kommen wird an dem
Russland endlich bereit ist über Frieden
zu sprechen aber wir als G7 tun alles
dafür dass die Ukraine dann so stark da
steht dass sie frei über ihre Zukunft
entscheiden kann die G7 senden ihre
Botschaft ihre Bilder bitte schauen Sie
in die Kamera
China und Russland sind in ihre
Botschaft ihre Bilder Pekings
Verteidigungsminister in Moskau
Präsident Putin lobt die sehr gute
Entwicklungen allen Bereichen in den
wirtschaftlichen sozialen kulturellen
und im militärischen
während sich die G7 in ihrer
Entschlossenheit gegenüber Russland
einig sind wird im Umgang mit China noch
das richtige Maß gesucht die Frage ist
was hilft noch mehr Härte oder noch mehr
Dialog über nukleare Abrüstung will
Japan am dritten Gipfeltag reden neben
Russland und China zwingt Nordkorea den
Westen zum Handeln
zurück nach Deutschland das Statistische
Bundesamt bestätigt was viele längst zu
spüren bekommen haben die
Verbraucherpreise für Strom und Gas sind
auch im zweiten Halbjahr 2022 weiter
gestiegen besonders stark verteuerte
sich Erdgas 9,34 Cent kostete eine
Kilowattstunde fast 37% mehr als im Jahr
zuvor beim Strom war der Anstieg
geringer 35 Cent je Kilowattstunde ein
Plus von
6,4%. wichtig die Entlastungen der
Bundesregierungen Bundesregierung sind
in diesen Zahlen bereits eingerechnet
die Hannover Messe das ist immer auch
ein Blick in die Industrie der Zukunft
und so widmen sich fast 200 Aussteller
in diesem Jahr dem Thema künstliche
Intelligenz ob Klimawandel unterbrochene
Lieferketten Fachkräftemangel bei all
diesen Herausforderungen kann KI Teil
der Lösung sein Svenja Domeyer hat
Beispiele ein Computerprogramm folgt den
Handbewegungen eines Mitarbeiters es
lernt wie Montageaufgaben auszuführen
sind optimiert Abläufe und kann das
Gelernte wiederum weitergeben so
funktioniert künstliche Intelligenz in
der Industrie hier haben wir ein Tool
entwickelt das auf künstliche
Intelligenz basiert was dafür sorgt dass
die neuen Mitarbeiter schnell und
effektiv eingelernt werden dass ihnen
auch beigebracht wird erstens wie sie
die Anlage gut zu bedienen haben und
zweitens wie sich aus Fehlern die sich
am Anfangsbereich machen dann noch
hinterher noch lernen
KI als Instrument gegen den
Fachkräftemangel anders als im Bereich
öffentliche Kommunikation vokai wegen
gefälschter Bilder wie diesen und
möglicher Desinformation skeptisch
betrachtet wird tun sich für industriebe
vor allem Möglichkeiten auf dank KI
müssen Arbeiter z.B keine
Schlüsselbegriffe mehr verwenden sondern
können Maschinen mittels natürlicher
Sprache steuern wo ist der
notfallschalter
befindet sich oben rechts viele
Unternehmen begreifen die neue
Technologie als Zukunft und Chance
wenn wir die Daten auslesen können haben
werden maschinenumfeld quasi unendlich
viele Daten aus denen wir mit KI lernen
können und Maschinen Zustände
vorhersagen können und optimieren können
das wird die Industrie definitiv
revolutionieren
wie kann Strom und Gas gespart wann am
besten Energie aus Sonne und Wind
genutzt werden auch hier soll KI helfen
das große Ziel Klimaneutralität
möglichst schnell zu erreichen
von Texas aus einmal in den Orbit und
wieder zurück in rund 90 Minuten das war
der Plan heute doch der unbemannte
raketentestflug der Firma SpaceX von
Multimilliardär Elon Musk wurde in
letzter Minute abgesagt kurz vor Ende
des Countdowns tauchten technische
Fehlermeldungen auf frühestens nach 48
Stunden wird es nun einen neuen Versuch
geben die 120 m hohe Rakete mit einer
Leistung von rund 30 Millionen pS Soll
erproben wie man eines Tages mannt bis
zum Mars gelangen könnte
jetzt tauchen wir einen in eine Welt die
ganze Generationen berührt und
begeistert
darin tummeln sich vertraute wie Micky
Maus das rehkitzbambi mit seinen
Freunden oder die Figuren aus der König
der Löwen vor 100 Jahren begann der
Trickfilmzeichner Walt Disney seine
beispiellose Karriere mittlerweile ist
Disney einer der größten Medienkonzerne
der Welt zum 100 Jubiläum gibt es eine
Ausstellung heute war Premiere in
München Jutta sonnewald
Micky als Dampfschiff Kapitän im Jahr
1928 Roald Disneys Maus sollte weltweit
noch groß Karriere machen vom Papier auf
die Leinwand wie sich der rundohrrige
Star und viele andere legendäre Disney
Figuren in den letzten 100 Jahren
entwickelt haben das zeigt eine
Jubiläumsschau in der Münchner
Olympiahalle was macht noch heute die
Magie dieser animierten Comic-Welt aus
Disney war ein Meister im Geschichten
erzählen was seine Charaktere von
anderen unterscheidet sind die Emotionen
zum Beispiel bei den drei kleinen
Schweinchen da hat jedes Schweinchen
eine ganz eigene Persönlichkeit
zum hundertsten Geburtstag hatte
amerikanische Medienkonzern seine
Schatzkammern geöffnet original Kostüme
wie corellas Kleid aus dem Film 101
Dalmatiner Cinderellas glasschuh oder
Luke Skywalkers Lichtschwert erstmals
stehen rund 250 original Disney
Requisiten Zeichnungen und Modelle so im
Rampenlicht hinter all diesen Geschöpfen
und Geschichten steht viel Energie und
Enthusiasmus
König der Löwen haben wir echte Löwen
ins Studio geholt nicht nur
Beobachtungen im Zoo es macht einen
Unterschied wenn sich zwischen dir und
dem Bleistift ein 900 Pfund schwerer
Löwe bewegt das spürt man dann auch auf
der Leinwand auf 1.500 Quadratmetern
können Besucher ab morgen in das
Universum all der großen und der vielen
kleinen rollt Disney-Helden eintauchen
eine Welt die auch nach 100 Jahren noch
fasziniert
Fußball fasziniert auch viele Norbert
beim DFB-Pokal der Frauen steht jetzt
das Finale Wolfsburg trifft auf Freiburg
nachdem die breisgauerin gestern Abend
ihr Halbfinalspiel in Leipzig mit 1:0
gewonnen hatten also durchaus verdienter
Sieg des SC durch einen sehenswerten
Last Minute Treffer der Freiburger
Kapazitäten zwei Kreise unterschiedliche
Stimmung links glückliche
Freiburgerinnen rechts ein ernüchter des
Leipziger Team das dennoch stolz sein
kann am Tag als der Aufstieg in die
Bundesliga feststeht leisten sie
gegenüberliegenden Erstligisten lange
erfolgreich Widerstand auch der Pfosten
hilft beim Weitschuss von Mertel die
Nachspielzeit läuft letzte Chance für
die Favoritin in eine Verlängerung zu
vermeiden und Freiburg gelingt doch noch
der Last Minute Sieg Hassi die Kapitänin
und Nationalspielerin schießt ihr Team
ins Finale gegen Wolfsburg
bemerkenswerte Randnotiz auch die Männer
tragen ein Halbfinale aus unter diesen
beiden Vereinen nur das Freiburg dann
Heinrich hat
[Applaus]
zu den Sonntagsspielen der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer nach der
Bremer eins zu zwei Heimniederlage gegen
Freiburg gab's zwei Unentschieden
Wolfsburg und Leverkusen trennten sich
torlos ja und Union musste sich mit
einem eins zu eins gegen Bochum
zufrieden geben Berlin gegen durch Josef
johannovic in der 45 Minuten mit einem
tollen Freistoß torenführung und danach
sorgte Kevin Stöger in der 55 Minute per
faul Elfmeter für den verdienten
Bochumer Ausgleich Union weiter Tabellen
Dritter der VfL mit einem wichtigen
Punkt gewinnen im Abstiegskampf weiter
auf Platz 15
alle Tore alle Höhepunkte des 28
Spieltag zusammengefasst zu sehen bei
heute.de und in der heute App zum
Boston-Marathon der im Zeichen des
schrecklichen Terroranschlags vor zehn
Jahren steht
am Samstag Gedenken an die Opfer drei
Menschen wurden 2013 getötet fast 300
verletzt heute dann am Mittag der
Startschuss für über 30.000
Sportlerinnen und Sportler zu Fuß oder
auch im Rollstuhl Gewinner bei den
Männern der Kenianer Evans cheze in 2
Stunden 5 Minuten und 50 Sekunden er
hatte schon letztes Jahr den Boston
Marathon gewonnen und bei den Frauen
Sieg der hellen obiri ebenfalls aus
Kenia in 2.21 38 ja und das alles bei
richtigen Schmuddelwetter
es ist nur ein bisschen besser morgen
wird es wolkig und eher kühl wie sich
Sonne und Regen verteilen erzählt gleich
Katja
das heute journal um 9:45 Uhr mit Maria
Slomka wir sagen danke und tschüss und
bis morgen werden sie morgen einen
schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend nach dem Recht trüben zum
Teil verregneten Wochenende brachte das
Hoch Petra heute am Montag doch viel
Sonnenschein hier in Schleswig-Holstein
auch in nördlichen Niedersachsen und es
scheint fast so als wollten sich diese
Wolken hier vor Großbritannien Staunen
zum Teil wurden sie auch einfach nur
aufgelöst was uns erhalten bleibt ist
diese nordostströmung damit kommen
Wolken heran aber auch Regenfälle heute
Nacht regnet es zwischen Niedersachsen
und Sachsen etwas und auch am alten Rand
die Temperaturen singen auf 6 Grad im
Thüringer Decken oder auch am Oberrhein
bis 0 Grad in der Eifel oder im Hunsrück
und morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 7 Grad in der Oberpfalz und 17
Grad am Oberrhein das wird ein
wechselhafter Dienstag strahlende
Sonnenschein gibt's in Nordfriesland
sonst überwiegen die Wolken das kann
auch ein bisschen regnen aber sehr viel
wird das nicht sein bei einem recht
lebhaften Wind aus Ost nordöstlichen
Richtung am Mittwoch drohen dann Schnee
Regen und Graupel Gewitter hier im
Nordosten der Donnerstag wird noch etwas
kälter dann kann es oberhalb von 400 bis
600 m in den West lichen Mittelgebirgen
etwas schneien der Freitag wird dann
deutlich milder guten Abend